Even though you're singing like verbally right,...
...I see so much expression going on with your, like whole body...
...and I guess you were kind of, like grasping the lyrics...
...and kind of putting into the... what's that like?
A lot of people know that every time I sing, like I'm really, really into it, the moment,...
...but when that time, when I couldn't even understand English or say a word,...
...my mom really, like taught me.
When I was singing an English song, you know,...
..she was trying to translate it to Tagalog...
...so I can understand it when I sing it in English.
So, that was like our technique. That's why I was feeling the song.
You know, the people thought that I knew what does it mean or whatever...
...because my mom has been translating it.
Alright, why don't you consider singing a song in Tagalog, like to the Philippine market?
Well, I mean I did.
I mean, I did sing a lot of Tagalog songs in the Philippines.
But you know, sometimes English songs are, like so popular in the Philippines...
...so that's why I'm mostly doing English songs.
But still, we have this music called OPM which means, like Filipino music and all that.
And I still sing Filipino songs. Until now, I still sing Filipino songs for them.
I mean, it's really important for them that I have a Tagalog tune.
That's why in my album, my debut album in the States,...
...there's this one song that I co-wrote and it has a rap on it.
This rap is famous in the Philippines.
And I wrote it, and it has Tagalog words...
...because it's really important for the Filipinos.